[Música]
se agudiza la crisis migratoria entre
polonia y belarús tras la llegada de
miles de migrantes a la frontera que
buscan cruzar hacia territorio de la
unión europea el presidente bielorruso
alexandr lukashenko es señalado por el
bloque de alentar a la migración como
una forma de presión ante las acciones
impuestas al país tras la represión
contra los opositores en las protestas
por las elecciones del pasado agosto de
el año 2020 la unión europea que
responsabiliza de la luz de la crisis
migratoria amenaza con nuevas sanciones
a empresas y también a personas una
crisis que se ha convertido en un
enfrentamiento político más allá de una
crisis humanitaria que deja en el medio
a miles de migrantes finalmente yo son
los que sufren para ello quiero saludar
en este momento a georg klein niente
politólogo investigador de la
universidad católica de einstein
ingolstadt en alemania profesor un gusto
saludarlo tenerlo nuevamente en este
nuevo espacio en directo de américa de
france 24 le pregunto cómo va la bruja
entonces se convierte en el punto clave
de esta crisis migratoria con europa por
la llegada estos migrantes a polonia
si es así es así por las actividades del
régimen belaruso tradicionalmente
bielorrusia no ha sido parte de los
corredores
para los refugiados de medio oriente y
es así básicamente por abrir un puente
aéreo para poblaciones sobre todo del
irak pero también de otros países para
esencialmente presionar a polonia a
lituania y algunos otros países vecinos
y aún en realidad hay que ver eso
también en el contexto de la crisis
general con rusia porque bielorrusia que
es un país pequeño relativamente a
polonia nunca haría eso nunca tomaría
pasos así de drásticos sin el apoyo de
su vecino rusia si es que eso le quería
eso le quería preguntar el profesor
porque mira el primer ministro polaco
mateusz morawiecki dijo que en efecto el
líder bielorruso alexandr lukashenko
a putin está orquestando la crisis pero
que es moscú el actor intelectual que
busca moscú detrás de todo esto
presionar a la unión europea en cuanto a
qué
en realidad ya desde más que siete años
moscú a perseguir una estrategia de
aumentar generalmente la atención la
conflictividad en europa porque se ve
generalmente beneficiado por una
situación de tensión o porque rusia está
fuera de los reglamentos
institucionalizados de europa de la
unión europea en realidad dado su
situación doméstica rusia no está capaz
de
participar en
una política regional
institucionalizada y se siente entonces
excluida de la política regional
institucionalizada y busca básicamente
ver un beneficio político
posiblemente también económico en
términos de los contratos de gas natural
etcétera para así en una situación
marcada por disputas
internacionales y también domesticados y
es que además el profesor no es la
primera vez que vemos este uso de los
migrantes como arma política porque
también lo vemos en el caso de turquía
que los manda de alguna manera por
grecia entonces digamos al final los más
afectados son los migrantes o los que
quedan en el medio de todo este
conflicto que puede hacer la comunidad
internacional para que al final estas
personas no sufran y los protagonistas
digamos de esto también que son los
migrantes son los que menos importan
entonces
sí es correcto luz las primeras víctimas
y los más afectados son los migrantes
que llegaron a bielorrusia por las
promesas
por las mentiras en realidad que les
hicieron por parte de los consulados de
los rusos en irak que ya se cerraron así
que básicamente esas actividades no van
a seguir de esta manera y aún varios
políticos resaltaron la necesidad de
informar mejor a las poblaciones en irak
y cuando se acaba en algún momento pues
ese esas medidas ilegales de bielorrusia
entonces uno podría pensar en cómo
tratamos qué hacemos para ayudar a las
poblaciones que ya llegaron y que a
veces ya están en minsk en una situación
frecuentemente dramática en términos
humanitarios
ahora yo gen como que podemos esperar un
futuro que se puede mejorar realmente
esta situación que se puede hacer para
mejorarla y qué va a pasar con los
migrantes y digamos que ya están
atrapados a dónde van a ir se quedan en
en bielorrusa pasan directamente a la
unión europea en europeas y los va a
[__] que va a pasar
no sabemos en realidad no es posible que
algunos se queden en belorrusia pero
cómo se van a sostener ahí
económicamente en un país que ya sufre
las consecuencias de las sanciones
europeas que en general tienen un bajo
nivel de desarrollo económico es posible
que algunos van a poder regresar a sus
países de origen y también es posible
que se encuentre alguna solución
humanitaria
en la unión europea para ellos o para
algunos de ellos pero para después para
llegar a un acuerdo a satisfacción te
primero creo que belorussia tiene que
terminar con sus intentos de amenazar la
frontera polaca porque básicamente lo
que es lo que sucede allá no es un
proceso de iniciado por los por los
refugiados es un proceso
iniciado por las autoridades bielorrusas